failed former president donald trump
claims he lost the four cell phones that
have just been subpoenaed by
leticia james uh i i know you're going
to say david how was that how is that
possible how is it possible he would
even try to say that but
there have been no consequences for
anything so why wouldn't he try to say
that look at this report from business
insider donald trump swears he has lost
four of the cell phones subpoenaed by
new york attorney general leticia james
what former president donald trump
swears he can't find four personal and
business cell phones that new york's
attorney general has demanded for her
probe of the trump organization
according to a new court filing i am not
aware of its current location and i do
not know its current whereabouts trump
says repeatedly of his most recent
recent business phone
two old flip phones plus a samsung
that he had used until it was taken away
from me at some point while i was
president
trump also swears in the filing he has
no additional personal business
documents to turn over and he doesn't
own nor use a business computer
i also do not use a computer for work
related purposes that does appear to be
true that that's been a thing for a
while there's actually a lot of ceos
that don't
use computers personally just to avoid
exactly this issue where their computer
might be requested for something uh the
affidavit was included as part of a
larger filing
the former president has been fined ten
thousand a day
since april 26th when a manhattan judge
arthur engeron
issued a written order holding trump in
contempt of court for failing to comply
with the attorney general leticia
james's subpoenas for documents and
records trump currently owes more than a
hundred thousand dollars in fines he has
started appealing the contempt order
calling the fine exorbitant and
unjustified
trump was known during his presidency
for keeping a cell phone always at the
ready for the firing off of incendiary
tweets but in his affidavit trump says
he lost track of some of these old
devices including the very phones the
attorney general believes could contain
information pertinent to the inquiry
trump says he believes the trump
organization last issued him a business
phone in 2015 it's just gone it
disappeared i am no longer
this must be some kind of typo i am no
longer have the cell phone in my
possession and i am not aware of its
current location
as for two flip phones and the samsung
he has owned since 2010 those are also
lost i do not know their current
location
i took the samsung with me to the white
house and it was taken from me at some
point while i was president i do not
have the samsung in my possession i do
not know its current work whereabouts
currently i own two personal mobile
phones one is an iphone he's had for
several years
and uh
he did submit that one for a uh for a
search so i mean listen does anyone
believe that he lost the four phones in
question no
no
but why not lie about it given that
there have been no consequences
whatsoever and that you're just trying
to run out the clock
um it seems as though you would
deliberately get rid of the phones that
that would be certainly one thing to do
and it may technically be true i mean if
you go by the letter he says he is not
aware of its current location that's
like if i say
uh i threw out a phone
it would be true that i am not aware of
its current location is it in a landfill
was it repurposed was it you know who
the hell knows it's technically true but
it's not the spirit of the situation so
as we've said before with almost all of
these different things
the strategy is obstruct
and delay the january 6th committee the
new york attorney general investigation
southern district all all these
different things that are going on
georgia
um obstruct to the extent that you can
and make legal arguments as to why the
obstruction should be allowed and then
delay with january 6th we know the point
of delaying
it is looking and i have to choose my
words carefully lest anyone in the
audience get mad at me it is looking
probable but it is not guaranteed that
republicans are going to take the house
in november and be sworn in to that
control in january if that happens the
january 6th committee is dead in the
water and of course anybody who has been
able to avoid dealing with the january 6
committee
you're good you're you're free
essentially and so that is the purpose
there and with a lot of these other
investigations you know in one of them
it started to become clear that there
was no real interest in charging trump
and investigators quit we covered that
story a few weeks ago
um so i don't believe any of it i don't
believe he lost the phones i mean if if
he doesn't know where they are it's
because they've been destroyed thrown
out whatever and it's technically
accurate but uh we know exactly what
they're doing and he will almost
certainly get away with it and we can
point fingers and say well it's just
merrick garland's fault or is it
it's actually far more complicated than
that there seems to be no genuine
willingness
to seriously consider charging the
president and immediate associates and
that has opened the door for them to do
whatever they can at the time to justify
not cooperating that's exactly what
trump is doing now with this for lost
cell phone thing
if you're looking for a therapist or
seeking treatment for mental health or
substance abuse check out compassionate
care compassionate care is a medical
practice offering
mental health treatment that's
affordable and remote
in the comfort of your home
compassionate care offers remote talk
therapy to patients nationwide you can
establish a meaningful long-term
relationship without having to drive to
an office for every appointment
psychiatry services are available
remotely to patients in pennsylvania and
new york compassionate care offers
medication assisted treatment for opioid
or alcohol addiction with the
medications buprenorphine and naltrexone
available in pennsylvania new york and
delaware compassionate care does not
require insurance they're a small
independent practice they support the
david pakman show and you can support
them and they're ready to talk to you
get a free consultation by calling 855
208
2408 or go to
caredrs.com the link is down below